les torontois l'ont attendu pendant deux
ans le célèbre défilé de la fierté gaie
est de retour dans la métropole pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
pandémie c'est l'occasion de se
rassembler et de se dire bonjour
waouh vous êtes encore là vous nous avez
manqué dit cet habitué du festival pour
d'autres comme ce père de famille qui a
récemment annoncé son homosexualité
l'événement est cependant une première
jean va pas je vais à part d'être moi
même lc stups est ok sert vraiment
stupide
cela juste de vie vive le hockey
il faut le vivre un vif avec l'amour
près de deux millions de personnes
étaient attendues dans les rues de la
ville dimanche pour les festivités une
occasion en or pour les commerçants de
toronto et pour la ville qui souhaite
relancer son économie les fonds sont
pleines les magasins sont pleines les
hôtels sont pleines et 7
nouveau bond de nouveau pour toute
l'économie et pour tout le
toronto les organisateurs indiquent que
le dispositif de sécurité a été
renforcée cette année en raison des
menaces auxquelles font face les
communautés lgbt qu plus dans le monde
des détecteurs de métal ont par exemple
été utilisée proche des semaines de
spectacles oui mais de de ce jeune le
directeur général de pride de toronto
explique avoir pris cette décision avant
la fusillade survenue à oslo en norvège
samedi près d'un bar gay selon lui le
drame confirme toutefois la nécessité
d'accroître la sécurité
pré festival est plus qu'une célébration
dit il il s'agit d'une manifestation
pour rappeler que beaucoup de membres de
la communauté lgbt qu plus ne peuvent
toujours pas vivre librement à travers
le monde roselyne droite mais cela me
fait chaud au coeur d'être dans un pays
où être gay est normalisée dans mon pays
ils viennent des valides et le droit à
l'avortement et maintenant ils vont
s'attaquer au mariage gay des plantes ce
festivaliers américain cette année les
organisateurs du festival ont misé sur
les talents locaux en tout plus de 300
artistes ont pris part aux festivités
dont plus de 275 originaire de la région
de toronto il s'entraîne williams phrase
au canada toronto